la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos presentó el tercer informe del
mecanismo especial de seguimiento al
asunto Ayotzinapa en el documento la
cidh expresa preocupación por algunos
aspectos por ejemplo la demora
injustificada en la aplicación de
órdenes de aprehensión y reiteran su
inquietud por la cancelación de 21
órdenes de atención que ya habían sido
libradas también advierten que a pesar
de que existe un contexto político
favorable al más alto nivel en la
alusión a la apertura que hay por parte
del ejecutivo persiste mucha resistencia
para entregar información o archivos que
están en manos de instancias de
seguridad nacional En este sentido
también advierten que la unidad especial
de investigación y litigación del caso
Ayotzinapa ha visto entorpecida su labor
Pues no ha tenido el mismo acceso a la
información que sí tienen por ejemplo la
comisión presidencial para el acceso a
la verdad y el propio hiey
establecen que es necesario profundizar
en la responsabilidad penal por el
delito de desaparición forzada con
especial énfasis en la cadena de Mando
política militar y de instancia de
seguridad civil recomiendan establecer
una política de comunicación que evite
la contradicción en la que han incurrido
las distintas instancias también
Proponen que sea un solo juzgado el que
tenga conocimiento de los distintos
procesos relacionados en el caso
Ayotzinapa las integrantes de la cidh en
conferencia de prensa en la Escuela
Normal Rural Raúl Isidro burdes de
Ayotzinapa refrendaron su compromiso
para acompañar a los a los familiares a
los padres de los estudiantes en la
búsqueda de justicia y acceso a la
verdad establecieron que el caso de la
desaparición de los 43 normalistas no es
aislado que se da en un contexto de
constante violación en los derechos
humanos en Guerrero y en un país en el
que hay más de 100.000 personas
reportadas como desaparecidas y 52.000
el cuerpos aún no identificados